Sí hola Buenos días la Unión Europea y
chile ya han cerrado hoy las
negociaciones para un nuevo acuerdo
marco de asociaciones mucho más amplio
que el que se cerró ahora hace 20 años y
que se convirtió en el primer acuerdo
que firmó la Unión Europea con un país
de América Latina el acuerdo permitirá
que el 99,9% de los aranceles entre
ambos bloques desaparezcan lo que
permitirá ampliar también las
exportaciones entre entre chile y
también la Unión Europea desde desde el
bando europeo aseguran que se podrá
exportar más de 4.500 millones de euros
a Chile uno de los puntos principales de
este acuerdo es el acceso a materias
raras a minerales algo muy importante
para la Unión Europea poder Acceder al
litio también al hidrógeno y al cobre
chileno especialmente porque la Unión
Europea quiere enfocarse en lo que llama
socios fiables y dejar de depender tanto
de China económicamente especialmente en
la cuestión de minerales el mismo acceso
que tendrán los inversores europeos
también lo tendrán los inversores
chilenos dentro del bloque europeo para
evitar cuestiones Como por ejemplo lo ha
ocurrido con el acuerdo de mercosur que
ahora mismo está bloqueado por parte
europea se tendrá sobre todo mucho
enfoque medioambiental existe el
compromiso por ejemplo en el caso de que
la minería siempre se explote que
siempre que se explote sea sostenible
según el acuerdo del clima de París
también la extracción de minerales
tendrá que hacerse bajo siempre en el
análisis de impacto medioambiental el
acuerdo de asociación además abarca más
cosas como por ejemplo el respeto a los
Derechos Humanos también al respeto al
Estado de derecho y sobre todo contiene
un capítulo específico sobre igualdad de
géneros la primera vez que la Unión
Europea tiene un acuerdo específico en
materia de igualdad de género en un
acuerdo comercial de hecho se trata de
un avance en las relaciones aseguran los
dos bloques que va a marcar las
relaciones de entre ambos bloques
especialmente en un contexto geopolítico
tan complicado marcado por la guerra en
Ucrania